how do we determine what's called a
candidate moolah tell me what's a
candidate so everybody here familiar
with the idea yes no no I got like a
mostly no so a candidate move is an idea
that was introduced into the world of
chess by Grandmaster Alexandra Kotov
maybe around the 50s and the idea is
that in a certain position because our
minds are relatively limited we only
consider a certain amount of moves those
certain amount of moves are what's
called the candidate moves or the moves
that we actually look at our computer
doesn't work like us a computer has no
candidate moves the computer brute
forces through every single move on the
board and every single reply and every
single reply to every single reply and
evaluates all of them and then
determines what's the best move we can
do that there are just too many
possibilities so in essence it looks
like chess is an impossible game to play
there's just way too many possibilities
but what actually happens in the
practical world is that your brain
quickly trims away 99.9% of the useless
moose that are in the board and you end
up focusing on things that make sense or
on things that you think might be
playable so in essence a candidate move
is what your brain tells you you have to
look at now how do you come up with this
how does your brain tell you I have to
look at this move any ideas
matters is a perfect example patterns is
and pattern recognition is a key element
of chess if you've seen a fork in a
previous game then it's more likely than
in the future you'll be able to
recognize a similar fork if you see an
open diagonal your mind immediately
recognizes the pattern of the open line
and it's like ah let's put a bishop
there if you have a position in which
your opponent just thread in the night
because he pushed upon and that pawn is
now running your knight you immediately
are aware that you have to do something
sure you can ignore it
you could counter-attack you could
defend it you can move it away but the
point is that your mind is doing
something against this threat your mind
is also always thinking about your own
threats about checks about threading
opponents pieces about winning material
over all the way that you come up with
candidate moves
besides pattern recognition it's
intuition when you see the player is
very intuitive usually means that they
see a lot of candidate moves that other
people might not consider so we're going
to more or less try to understand how
grandmasters at least I come up with
with candidate moves and how I organize
them in my mind I start thinking about
different variations so we're going to
go through a lot of examples of some
tactics some pretty basic tactics I
actually got this from a recent book
that came out by Jacob Agard I I'm the
name of the book slips my mind right now
but it's a nice series of ideas that he
takes from Kotov and improves upon
gotough is the guy that said candide
moves are the way to go in chess and of
course back in the 50s chess wasn't
fully understood understood and he made
some mistakes and his other theories but
over are the overall the candidate with
idea it's kind of kind of a success so
let's take this position for example
we have on the board you're black in
this position and it's your to move
obviously if you were white the rook
takes the knight and the game is over so
that wouldn't be too much fun to teach
but since you're black it's actually
more interesting so let's go back to
this pattern issue what do we
immediately notice about the position
there's a potential mate throw right I
mean the dock King looks a little a
little iffy it's not a very happy King
there's a bishop on the open diagonal
there are some weak square surrounded
there are some threats
so immediately you're thinking oh maybe
I can do something about it there's
actually a real game of all the examples
that I will show our real games today
today at least this one is between
Grandmaster gawad who plays in America
relatively often and International
Master Leon Edgar joy who I believe is
American played in Philadelphia last
year and even grandmasters blind-spot a
lot of things in this position
Gullit was probably counting on the fact
that black would play Knight f3 check
and when you see the position that's
probably the first move that comes up to
you on your mind you give a check you're
attacking the rook you're potentially
forcing that exchange of a bishop and
putting your queen in a very threatening
situation so let's see what happens 9 of
3 check what does white have to play
Bishop takes there's no choice right so
after 9 of 3 Bishop takes Queen takes
probably right there there's no real
harm done to white if I take with the
bishop possible but nothing special
Queen takes and I'm threatening Queen G
2 and Queen h4 checkmate which would be
unstoppable
except that white still has a resource
what what is it before blocking the
coordination between that Bishop and the
Queen so unfortunately for for us
neither 3 isn't all that great it's nice
I do get the bishop and
certain positional advantage but I'm not
winning any material and actually after
Eve for my pawn on d6 is hanging he's
about to quit to kick out my queen on f3
with rook d3 you know it's okay but it's
not particularly great and of course
it's my my guess that God saw that
position and he was like oh that's not a
problem but he failed to consider all
the candidates so we have the idea of
the knight of three doesn't really work
how else can we try to take advantage of
this weekend lights course
so we have this idea of Queen f3 and
this ties directly in with the knight of
three track idea not of three check was
devastating and it had to be answered
with Bishop takes what Queen of three is
essentially saying is that the knight of
three check is so devastating I can you
know give up my queen for it and let's
analyze after Queen of three can he play
E for and block out the Queen and Bishop
coordination why not they're still a
made on G to write the knight on h4
because it's alive it's still protecting
g2 therefore Queen f3 4 is not a
possibility
so after Queen f3 there's only one thing
to check Bishop takes f3 right how does
black proceed it's not a not a trick
question yeah neither three check now
usually I don't like saying I I really
hate when the answer to or oh that's not
good I really hate when people say you
know Knight check and the King moves and
I play this let's try let's try to
always think a little bit more precisely
in this case it actually doesn't matter
where on the diagonal he moves but in
some cases it does so let's pretend King
g2 just to give an exact position to the
king so we have three Bishop takes
Knight takes f3 checking g2 how should
watch black follow
Knight takes rook check right so I'm
throwing the Queen for free and a
turning Chuck
so probably White's best choice is to
interpose the queen and after Queen e4 I
have to take the Queen right Bishop
takes Queen Knight takes bishop we're in
a position that how would you categorize
it black doesn't have a good game
all right anybody else wanna so this is
the idea it's too many moves ahead so
let's try to visualize that position
this is the hard part of calculating
Queen f3 right Bishop takes Knight takes
f3 King G - Knight takes d4 check
Queenie for Bishop takes e4 Chuck Knight
takes e4 now let's analyze the position
or in our head let's visualize how many
pieces are left and that's counted cuz
that's always important it's knowing how
many pieces are left on the board so
let's start with white how many pieces
does he have left what's still alive
guys are working tonight right yeah
[ __ ] gun okay all right what about
black
- Rose - Robson tonight so with the
power of maths
what are we up
good power of mass dirkson tonight
against the Brooklyn tonight want to go
all right okay yeah and then your upper
rook in that position which is winning
by all means right so let's review girl
a bit bio they played Queen f3 and gall
and immediately resigned okay he had
completely blundered this idea of of
Queen f3 and he blundered at first
because it's not logical for most
grandmasters to be like oh they had a
queen I'll put the Queen I'm free but
you know there's a sense to them after
Bishop takes Knight takes check King G 2
this would have happened takes in
Queenie 4 takes takes and of course once
you put it on the board it's very easy
to see how ya Box winning he's a baroque
so we're gonna try to visualize this
positions at the end and make sure that
we get the result that we want alright
so that was example number one it was
relatively you see there were only two
candidate moves and not much to it let's
take it up a notch I'm gonna skip this
one for now
this before now I'm gonna start with
this one
this one is a different type of puzzle
and isn't so much we're not gonna be so
much worried about calculating as much
as creating our candidate news most
difficult part of this puzzle is coming
up with the right move once you see that
right move you'll realize that you're
winning but coming up with the move is
not the easiest thing in the world
there's actually a girls game
if I remember correctly it's Neville
Cena is white against question Shia
pushing Shia is the I don't know if
she's the Russian champion but she's
definitely one of the twin sisters who
are that one and two Russian players
actually they're not transistors but
they're sisters
alright so white is threatening rook h3
that's not a subtle threat but it is
very lethal after we're caged three
Queen takes h6 is checkmate
so our intuition our brain is
immediately like oh my god we have to
defend from this notice also that white
might be threatening 95 or 9h five and
taking on f6 which also seems very very
dangerous so I would like to eliminate
that night so the first kind of in roofs
comes pretty obvious which is
pawn takes knight it remember is this
candidate moves I didn't say moves that
you're gonna play this moves that you're
gonna analyze so it takes that for upon
text night and why I'm not giving her a
lot of choices is probably going to play
well as her other threat
besides moving tonight rook age three
right so with rook age three she's
running checkmate on h6 and can I
protect from this a quick glance at the
position shows that the rook cannot
actually protect h6 on a rock on g8
obviously the rookin see it can even
less protect on on age sex the Queen on
c7 can protect I'd six either and the
night on a five might as well not be on
the board so I'm getting made it that's
it there is nothing else to see so
context nine losses to rock age three
simple simple truss so what to do
you could counter-attack yes it could
counter-attack how do you counter an
attack in this position sorry you could
check but of course when you check
because it can be checked made usually
you do that check for free when you
sacrifice the Queen for it I'm not sure
it's such a great idea
after Queen c1 check the problem is that
rook takes rook takes the King escapes
with actually oh well rook takes pawn is
always interesting in this position but
as long as White has the night they can
always capture with the knight and then
there's nothing to analyze him simply
down a rook remember that black doesn't
even have that much extra material in
this position in essence I'm only up a
pawn and it's not like a very great
point it's like a double pawn so rook
takes doesn't work oh but it was a
candidate move for last at all like 15
seconds of glory but it was a candidate
move pawn takes Knight didn't work
either so let's throw out kind of the
mistakes that you have to see come on go
sure Queen see one shot rook takes rook
takes right the problem is that the rook
by itself is a terrible perpetuating
piece and this is true for most trust
games I mean doing a perpetual with the
rook is really really unique
yeah Queen can easily perpetual the king
but because of the way that the pieces
moved the rook is always going to be
like caught up by the King just by
moving up and down in the diagonal
yonder on the ranks and it's gonna be
like it's never gonna be a perpetual
furthermore the knight on f4 is still a
defensive piece so I can always retreat
it to e2 and and that should just win
easily in any case so Quincy won check
unfortunately gives away too much
material for very little value in this
position so not Queen c1 and not
politics nod rook takes pawn either
Quinn d8m try to maneuver the Queen to
f8 seems like a reasonable move if Queen
da roca ch3 at least I can put my queen
on a fade and I'm not getting checkmated
immediately problem is that after 95 my
position is really passive and he's
threatened and while she is turning
Knight takes f6 check my King sight
position is collapsing I have no
counter-attack I'm not even up a pawn
and I will probably be resigning rather
soon soon something after all the
fashion show as a grandmaster
so yeah on the lack of a better move you
would think we need at least four vice
for a little bit but not very long but
at least we got a candidate moved to
protected h6 unfortunately all right so
we got a real catchy the problem with
the rocket shade is that well they're
actually several but after rook h3 king
g8 I still have 95 my position is still
not good at all the attack should be
winning somehow easily in the next few
moves in essence I removed the defense
and this is something that comes up very
quickly in candidate moves at least two
grandmasters it's like oh you realize
you can't defend you stop blocking a
defensive moves because route g5 rook g7
rotate shade Queen d8 27 by the way that
was a bunch of candidate moves I just
threw out they all fail because there's
not enough resources to actually hold
the King sight together
they're just armed
so we start thinking about
counter-attack Quincy - is the first
thing that you think of because Quincy
to rock age 3 Queen takes G to checkmate
unfortunately there's still a knight or
not for so Quincy - doesn't actually
threaten anything it's a cool-looking
move but cool-looking moves and actually
threatening things sir Quincy for Quincy
for what does Quincy for threatened well
more than the d4 pawn indirectly it's
throwing the a1 rook because once I take
on d4 notice that I'm forking the King
on g1 and the rook on a 1 now why
doesn't have time after Queen c4 to play
rock edge to me a very simple look at
the position reveals that Queen takes d4
Chuck he has to go to f1 because it's
getting he's getting background mated in
h1 I take the rook he moves the King
forward and I bring my rook that's
currently not doing anything on c8 to c2
and the funny thing is this basically
the position that we were looking at
before but I have an extra queen
remember the Queen see one variation
yeah but I have an extra Queen extra
Queens are nice and in this position is
just over I mean there's just too many
chucks and the main is that maid will
follow up quickly so after Queen c4
white can't play rock edge 3 I can't
move my Knight to d5 or h5 either
because that doesn't protect from the
threat on d4 so after Queen c4 White has
to come up with some way of defending
this position any ideas
you can retreat the Queen right so let's
look at Queen f2 Queen C for Queen have
to the problem is that white was on the
offense and when they go back to the
defense there is some move that I wanted
to play really badly and it was the
first kind of didn't move that we looked
at that I can play now
so after Queen C for if you retreat the
Queen won't what can i play he takes
that for correct after pawn takes Knight
there's no longer any pressure on the
h-file and therefore black is just
winning in that position so after Queen
C for I can't defend with my queen my
queen is basically stuck on the H file
because of I need root page three to
take on age sex
so I'll define my pawn like this there
is one piece that it's not doing
anything let's make it do something
rook d1 Queen C for rugby one
so let's continue the attackers Black
River I still don't have any defensive
who some pawn takes hasn't changed
anything Ponte still fails to reach age
three so if that's the case what do I
play now well take the knight rook h3 is
still not still not great not terrible
actually there is a variation where it's
not that bad but then let's let's we'll
ignore them there there's a better move
and we're precisely if you will remember
that in the previous edition of my
haters on the candidate moves we said
that Queen c2 was cool looking but it
didn't threaten anything now I would
because after Queen c2 what am i hitting
the rook right so let's say I play Queen
c2 now he has to move the rook away
right I mean there's no choice remember
that I'm checking and mating so let's
say that they go to f1 roopd f1 now what
can i play finally that I've always
wanted to play take the knight and what
happens if rook h3 there's made on g2 so
see how the counter-attack by black
allows me the time that I needed to
basically out when they win the night
and whether the game in this position
we actually went through a bunch of
candidates really really quickly I'll
point it out we looked at pawn takes we
looked at I don't remember the order we
looked at pawn takes Queen c1 Queen c2
we looked at Queen d8 and then we
quickly eliminated all the defensive
moves Queenie salmon rub g5 rookie
Soraka Jade that's eight right there and
then we finally came with the correct
solution ix camden move Queen c4 and the
way that you come up with candidate
moves is very interesting
many of them were refuted easily like
Queen c1 some of them were refuted with
a little bit of a difficulty like pawn
tanks you have to see rook h3 that
there's no defense afterwards some were
a little bit tempting like Queen d8 and
trying to defend passively because we
didn't see anything better and then the
mind said that hold on let's not look at
defensive moves let's try to go to the
counter-attack allowed us to finally
visualize the winning move caution
shower did play Queen c4 and I believe
the game ended I did not make this black
a chef Wow
all right Queen c4 and root d1 is pretty
much forced in this position I think
context is okay in this position for
Queen c2 stronger rook DF 1 and then
pawn takes and with no time to play
rotates three White's position is just
completely lost in this position in this
position oh the problem in 92 is that
this Queen is actually Queenie 696 oh
you could sit there all day but I'm
gonna take you and then Queen d4 is
still a threat right so you basically
gave the night for no no good reason and
I'm pretty happy here I'm up a piece so
yeah if we had a solid way of defending
d4 they'd be almost winning but they
don't they don't have a good way of
defending the pawn and the check and
everything that comes with it for
example if they remove the King to h1 I
can simply take the knight because now
you put yourself in a bank or in a
background situation so you can't move
the rook to h3 see the problem for white
is that they can't defend the pawn in a
useful manner and that's good for us
that means that you win the game
all right any questions about this
example everybody good
I thought you know I work this in the
next example
it's a French game the French
co-champion fresene a is white in this
position and here we're gonna come up
with a bunch of moves maybe you guys
will see it immediately maybe you won't
depends on your strength depends on your
visualization so white has a pretty nice
position immediately you can guess that
this was a d4 opening somehow probably a
semi Slav or something like that
something that went awfully wrong for
block because I can't even gossip but in
the game of chess awfully wrong doesn't
mean losing until you give them the coop
did a lot in this position I have to
figure out something with white or
eventually black will play h6 and try to
slither their way away from their way
away from the center and maybe equalize
eventually so looking at the position
what are some resources that you
immediately look at
all sevens week right so if I could
manage to put more pressure on f7 than
golden the problem is the knight takes
f7 right now doesn't do very much
because there's no night to replace the
one on gq5 of course the knight on a
four bus on f3 I could think of
something like Knight takes f7 Knight g5
and kill him somehow unfortunately after
Knight takes f7 and kind of running low
on resources so then we think about
Bishop g6 because that's our idea that's
how we think we want to put pressure on
f7 therefore we look at we look at
Bishop g6 can you take with the H pawn
that just drops the rook right I'm up in
exchange and whatever happens happens
but I hope the exchange and I'm happy
with my life so there's only one move
that I can seriously be concerned with
with the Queen so let's see Bishop g 6f
takes g6 right now the first suggestion
has Queen b6 you're threatening one
another non trick question
you're threatening checkmate on f7 what
if black plays Bishop d5
am i covering up something yeah because
the bishops on the diagonal the bishops
defended because of the 911
so I have to retreat but I'm done a
piece so it seems a little awkward to
sacrifice a piece and then be like
alright I'm out so they don't really
work
yeah but after king of Savin it we kind
of agree that there was not no real way
of reinforcing that attack right so in
this position let's look back at Bishop
g6 cuz it looks it looks it looks good
right it almost wins and then huh that's
right
and a little bit of an unusual
combination the knight own a forest
strangely important because after Bishop
g6 which did happen in the game I think
black resigned pawn takes Knight takes
c6 the queen is trapped on d8 therefore
black is completely lost in this
position kind of an usual right but a
cool a cool little combination all right
we're going to go into this position and
this is actually one of the most famous
missed chances of the of the year this
was played back in January and players
are super grandmasters there was no just
grandmasters super grandmasters white is
gushing wolf lugar Kashima from
azerbaijan 27 something and his opponent
is navara from i want to say the czech
republic yes I'm a hundred percent sure
on that one also 2700 so you're playing
white in this position and let's analyze
the situation how's the material count
even right not a trick question you guys
can counter the pieces I'm not gonna
hide them from you material semen but
what's going on in the positional sense
why holds the H file which is
immediately dangerous right there's a
king on g8 and there's a lot of almost
checkmates going around right
immediately our mind starts thinking
things like Knight takes g7 I'm sure
that everybody's like oh my god Knight
takes g7 unfortunately 19 she simply
doesn't work because after King takes g7
there's a rook on d6 defending the
knight on h6 and there's no way to
really continue the attack that's pretty
clear right now therefore we're a little
stumped on candidate moves another move
that you are immediately like oh my god
I'm gonna play that as Queen g5 I'm
running mate on g7 and everything's
hanging but of course Queen g5 doesn't
work because Queen takes me so G 5 is
covered H 6 is covered brings in the
Queen em seems a little small a little
slow but it's not terrible something
like Queen F 2 and G 3 or I don't know
something like that but you know a lot
of grandmasters see this position they
just smell blood
so Kashima actually misses this move but
let's see hmm well we have this idea
Rock takes a salad but what's the what's
the point obviously he has to take
there's no all right so rook takes e7
Queen takes c7 9 f6 Chuck the point is
that if you take with the pawn I take on
h6 I'm guessing right with the Queen and
I'm pretty sure that's checkmate in the
next move long as they play like Queen
c1 or something but who cares the
problem with this line is the rook c7
Queen c7 Knight f6 check rook takes f6
remember there's a rook on the
third-ranked the most annoying recovered
by the way defending pretty much all
room c6 is an idea but our Bishop c6 the
problem is that the bishop on d5 is so
perfectly placed right now that I don't
want to move it from there
because that bishop looks awesome it's
spinning the f7 pawn it's in the center
it's like that's a rocking bishop so now
we combine candidate moves we wanted to
play Queen g5 very badly but we couldn't
so let's check out if it works now rook
C sine Queen c7 Queen g5 so I'm
threatening the very subtle made on g7
so black has to figure out a way to stop
it
let's see what happens if you place f6
he can't play up sexist Grandmaster
title is revoked the movies illegal and
and and and the world goes on f6 and f5
are not legal moves because of my
beautiful bishop on d5 rook not have sex
that doesn't protect I mean Jesus rook
g6 right but it's the rook defended it's
not Queen takes g6 because of my
beautiful bishop on d5 so that doesn't
help you what other move defense from
checkmate King edge sermon doesn't
actually protect you seven I can still
check maybe in g7 it's just a little bit
different there's night at five which
accomplishes absolutely nothing after I
take it with a pawn so the only thing
worth looking at is g6 however this is
not terribly difficult to refute after
g6g six leave something hanging which is
good for us the night so you take the
night threatening checkmate on g7 same
thing so what if they take my night so
that's visualizer FC sorry Queen c7
Queen g5 g six forced Queen takes h6
pawn takes h5 how do I continue here
almost but there's a rook remember
there's a rook on d6 Queen g5 check is
correct
now he can't cover with the rook because
I'd just taken that hasn't changed and
if he moves to the h-file rook takes
nami but quasi maid right so the
variation goes like this rook c7 Queen
c7 is forced okay he can technically
move the Queen away somewhere like d8
and or something and survive a few more
moves but you're losing the you're
listening all your pieces
that's not very pretty so Queen here
Queen g5 this bishop guards this this
pawn is pinned this doesn't help Black
Knight a5 is just a waste of a move and
everybody's time so g6 is forced Queen
takes threatening game Queen g7 one
takes Queen check rogue g6 is again now
to move because it's hanging
so King h8 or something and the rook
which was the real quick was too you
know we knew it was dangerous from the
beginning delivers the fatal blow and
that's it it's over next it was missed
yeah you know it was one of those
surprises of chess you know everybody
like everybody on their grandmother's
side online and they're like oh my god
how did he not see it but okay blind
spots happened to him and top
grandmasters they're like most likely
theories that he forgot that after rook
g6 he can just take the rook now that
it's a fantastic explanation but I mean
that's the best I can do
of course everybody was watching with
engines and they're like oh Roxy so
anyways
all right here your block and one person
already solved it in the room so I'm
sorry but it's a good example for the
for the question you're black and in
this position you have to decide what
you're gonna play so obviously you have
an attack the King on h3 is now the
happiest king that's ever lived however
there are a couple threats for example
Knight takes d4 might be a threatening
text that five is definitely a threat so
I have to do something so sometimes the
way that you whittle down things is you
eliminate them quickly you look at them
you're like this doesn't work and you
move on and sometimes it'll be five
moves that you eliminated in 30 seconds
and you get out of them so alright
Canada moves go go don't think their
candidate missing
rook takes which pawn there's three okay
rook takes you three go go go candidate
who is this nice hg3 go go rogue thanks
h4 go go row gauge to check go go go
this is candidate mu C Queen takes h4
sure go any other moves Knight thanks
it's either g3 or f4 f4 rope that night
thanks f4 that's six go on what about
something not that's not actually like
killing all your pieces what about
something more normal
so sure see five why not see five okay
any other ideas and you catch to us
already mentioned so we already got them
in the our asked about some roller moves
or Knight f6 Queen g7 so I got nine
moves yeah we're gonna look how fast
we're gonna go through them c5 pawn
takes that didn't change anything
nope not that one rook takes that fork
has to be wrong because rook takes that
four and I didn't improve my position
improved his two out of the way nineteen
three three Oh certainly we have to
think because he cannot take on g3 with
the rock because of rook rook or Queen
takes h4 Jackman but Knight takes g3 he
takes my rook that was my most important
attacking piece unless I have checkmate
right now this is like over I don't it's
over
alright it's not so hard to see that the
knight on g4 is defending everything and
I have to take it and after I take it
he's gonna take my night with the King
and I'm out of pieces to mate I mean
it's very simple to see that there I'm
out of pieces to check me on that
position
nah Knight f4 sorry so we just looked at
night thanks g3 right non Knight to c3
let's rook on Rupe thanks g3 erupt eggs
g3 is forced
this is how I eliminate this quickly if
I wanted to do that I'll sacrifice on h4
and I don't know previous rook does that
make sense
rook g3 Andrew cage for equivalent but
in one I approved is working in the
other the ropes on g1 does that make
sense
so I eliminated that let's eliminate the
obvious was Knight f6 doesn't do
anything Queen G seven traits Queens
into a lost endgame that's six what else
have we mentioned so Brooke h2 rook
takes h4 and Queen takes h4 our left row
get you to check we can also eliminate
with our rather easily rotate to check
what's see the beautiful thing is that
we have a bunch of our agents but white
only has one move against them so we
don't have to spend all day calculating
row gauge - but white plays now
therefore didn't work yeah because of
rook takes that for improving his rook
and eliminating my powerful Knight so
row gauge to check for skin takes h2 now
I'm assuming that I sacrifice the rook
not because I like sacrificing drugs but
because I had a purpose in mind so we
immediately look at route 2 x h4 Chuck
right I mean what else
if pawn takes we can see that queen x h4
Chuck kingi - queen g3 Chuck King h1
Queen h3 is checkmate everybody follow
that line I'll repeat it rotates to
check King takes h2 roped x h4 pawn
takes rook Queen takes pawn Kim G -
Queen g3 Chuck King h1 Queen h3
checkmate excellent right alright we
doubled we double tag so we don't burn
your stuff before we play rock edge to
check King takes a ch2 group takes h4
wait he doesn't have to take that right
after rook takes h4 check King G to
simply wins for white there is no
there's no rule in justice that says
that you have to take your opponent's
pieces
so so it's it's completely lost but you
can maybe do it backwards if he's not
forced to take on h4 in that variation
suddenly we got this idea of doing it
the other way around so let's look at
rook takes h4 check first
now pawn takes is forced and hit me
continue now rock h2 is checkmate
after King takes Queen takes King G to
Queen Queen g3 King h1 to h3 now the
funny part is that Rakesh
why don't I keep setting this with the
rough side okay rook takes pawn takes
actually what you do is it's over
it's finito but if you want to be more
elegant you can be like Queen takes and
takes for a pitch to me and since you
figure this out in the in the real game
you'll choose a 9th candidate move
because you're cool like that and you'll
take with the Queen which leads to the
same position after pawn takes rook
takes the King still trapped there
checking
so sometimes you get confused by a lot
of candidate moves but a lot of them you
can actually dissipate rather easily
either because they're not in the spirit
of the position or because they're not
threatening anything or because you're
reporting simple replies possum will
just win against them this position had
nine candidate moves which is like an
obnoxiously large amount for a common
position most positions I'm looking at
two three moves usually one you know a
very complicated tactic I'll be looking
at five and yet this one didn't take us
all that long to solve and the reason is
that a lot of candidate moves can pretty
much be dealt with in an appropriate
manner by simply discarding them once we
know they don't work
I understand what you're saying about
the tree and stuff but to those that
don't know there's this concept that a
candidate move branches out you can
create a tree afterwards because for
example if you look at it in a diagram
version you know there's a candidate
move that spawns four replies and each
reply spawns four replies and each reply
of each reply spawns four replies and
eventually you get a tree of variations
now in real chess and there is no such
thing as a consistent tree of variations
this was thought to be the case for many
years that you know every Grandmaster
constantly calculated all although all
this stuff all the time but to be fair
most positional games are just like oh
my pieces belong here boom I play it
it's only when it's only when our minds
start thinking there's danger there's
tactics there's threats that we start
really calculating that's why it's very
common that positional tricks succeed
because in very positional a positional
trick is for example when there is no
way a knight can get to an outpost but
you use a small tactic to actually get
it there I can intermediate or something
because in the positional struggle you
are now looking for tactics and suddenly
tactics serve strategy and you got your
outpost so it's as confusion then and
and this kind of like lack of awareness
that allows a lot of these tricks to
work when when you're in a position that
is relatively you know solid it's it's
not it's nothing not too much is going
on even for me it'll it'll be rare to
start calculating stuff or to create
trees I'm just I just know that there
are some positions in which I have to
look at the position and be like okay
this this looks correct I'll play it
yeah
the way forcing moves work is that they
eliminate a lot of things that you have
to look at for example if if you make a
move and your opponent replies with a
forcing move that you know forces you to
reply some well usually that's actually
awesome for your calculation because
that means you don't have to think about
a bunch of stuff you just have to think
about you know your force reply the same
thing that when you create a forcing
threat you know you don't have to
calculate a million variations you have
to just consider the the way that your
opponent can reply to to set it to that
threat so it's not a it eliminates
candidate moves but it makes your
analysis a lot easier just because
there's less noise to watch out for
that's why they're called forcing this
writing like I'm forcing you to do this
there's no reason they're called that
for example this this variation
specifically was very easy for us to
analyze because I mean pretty much all
our candidate moves for forcing moves
you know everything that we played had
only one reply by by white which allowed
which was awesome because it allowed us
to go through everything very quickly
any other questions
I think we have time for one more
example but unfortunately I think we'll
get time to see the game material
deficit but in the other hand we are we
have a lot of positional strong values
for example we have the pair of bishops
with a strong knight on d5 and we have
one tactical cool thing that should be
obvious to everybody there's a pin
there's a pin on the C file so our minds
and that's how they think they're like
can I can I win that bishop because that
would be awesome because I want to win
it because three bishops are awesome so
in this position how can i attack the
bishop with your bishop because if he
takes my bishop I take a look so that
gives us two candidate moves Bishop d6
and Bishop a7 which one's better why a 7
because it because it takes the diagonal
that's with the Kings oh wow instantly
we eliminated one candidate it's not
Bishop d6 Bishop a7
now however Bishop a7 is competing
against Bishop takes a 4
Bishop takes a 4 is slightly more
accurate but Bishop e7 is perfectly
playable the reason is that after Bishop
a7 I still have to in some lines
calculate what happens if he
intermediates me after Bishop takes a 4
whereas after Bishop takes a 4 I have to
worry about this stuff we should take
say for context and then after Bishop a7
I'm actually threatening that bishop so
your white bishop takes a 7 row take c1
looks like a very ugly on the game
blacks up a pawn my Kings a little weak
and a4 is hanging in many variations so
when your black Bishop takes pawn takes
Bishop a7 don't waste your time
wondering how is that endgame after
Bishop takes a saying will I be able to
win that in game just by your up upon so
we have to analyze how he defends the
bishop can he retreat the bishop let's
say Bishop e3 cool gmf does it work can
I take the bishop
with the night you could take with the
bishop working the works but then what
others white replied rogue take CA check
right unfortunately for you the bishop
was pinned but nobody was spinning the
Rexy one that reckons the one is cool so
Bishop takes pawn takes Bishop a7 Bishop
e3 there was a reason we put that Bishop
on any seven rook takes c1 check
distract the bishop on e3 which is
forced to take the rook and now I can
actually make pretty much any legal move
and I'll be winning except like 96 or 93
as long as I don't block the diagonal
I'm gonna recover the exchange either on
this move for the next move and I am up
a well what am i up no the exchange
remember I'm down the exchange now so
when I'm down the exchange now and I win
an exchange so I'll be up upon and being
a pawn in an endgame is pretty awesome
actually that's just completely winning
for black all you have to do is push the
ponds so Bishop takes pawn takes Bishop
a7 we eliminated Bishop b3 and Bishop e3
because Bishop a3 doesn't actually
change anything right I can at least
take on c1 now some people will be like
oh but against Bishop a3 I might have
something stronger you know don't worry
about it you already know that drill
takes me one is good enough if that
problem presents itself on the board
worry about it then you already know you
have a good solution move on Bishop
takes pawn takes from bishop a7 is there
any other move I have to worry about we
eliminated all the bishop moves pretty
much then he just flat out defend the
bishop
he could play row Cassie - now notice
that there is no before because that
punim v3 took the bishop on a four so
rooks it - it's a possibility now what
what Canada moves do you come up with
four back how you could play 93 but
after 93 you are unfortunately unpinning
yourself your opponent so there's always
a right way to do things
you could retreat we have six but maybe
four so the problem that if six that he
has you're not running anything right
now so he sent time to move the King and
kind of move away from the threats
because he's no longer pinned not to
mention that I think we should take say
Simon just wins because my rook on c2 is
defended so night before night before if
I take on a seven what happens rook
takes rook and if rook takes rook Knight
takes rook and I'm updating upon yeah
yeah I'll be up a pawn in all these
variations that's right
if I ask something the answer is
probably all yeah yeah I'm up upon so
Bishop takes pawn takes Bishop a7 rook F
c2 night before he can take my bishop he
cannot legally take my knight because
there's a pin and I'm threatening the
rook on c2 so he must do something so
let's assume that he moves the rope
let's say Roxy for just for argument's
sake so after rook c4 how do I continue
the problem 93 is that remember that
that Bishop on a7 is actually not pinned
sorry the one who's c5 therefore my
bishop on a7 is hanging it's not
actually so important that you're
forking the pieces but in that variation
that Brooklyn c5 cannot be defended
again and it's in an absolute pin so I'm
gonna I'm gonna repeat what he said to
everybody in the room the line is like
this and try to visualize Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes knight Knight be sorry
Bishop e7 hitting the Bishop rook F c2
forced night b4
now the route moves away because it's
attacked
Brooksie for now the Bishop on c5 is not
not pin so it's running my bishop
so I'll eliminate it if I eliminate it
with my bishop then the rook on c5 is
free to move
if I eliminate it with my rook the
bishop on a seven is still pinning so
the correct move is rook takes e5 rook
takes c5 and 93 at the end is not only a
fork it's actually an absolute pin on
the rook on c5 which cannot be defended
anymore and after I take on c5 I'll be
up well actually not a piece - two minor
pieces for a rock and a pond which is
awesome so that's actually the winning
variation the bishop a7 now from now on
the best move for white will be to
eventually sacrifice the exchange and
just be down upon but the endgame is
relatively hopeless Rock FC Thun I
before
now the next hitting the rook so this
bishops pinned and if he tries to move
it away rook c5 rook c5 and that's the
game it's over
so notice that we actually came up with
candidate moves only when we had to at
many points we were like I have to do
something or he has to respond to my
threat therefore we start creating
candidates while at some points were
like well there's nothing to see here
let's move on for example when I win the
exchange I don't dwell in the position
like what am I going to do afterwards
can I win the endgame
it's just I'm up the exchange compared
to how I started that's awesome that
stopped there black actually missed this
which is funny there's lot there were a
lot of missed opportunities and the
things that in the games that I gave you
and the game was eventually drawn after
she suffered a lot she played before
which he thought was winning because
because of this fork and it ends up that
after rook t1 White has no problems
because of this idea okay but we don't
even have to go into night before
because our most obvious move was Bishop
a7 and we correctly analyzed this
candidate moved to the to completion and
once you analyze the kinda to move to a
win you don't have to worry about other
stuff you're just like okay this wins
let's apply it also they were probably
in time pressure I mean like a lot of
these games are like they're much easier
solved or the board with the Grandmaster
explaining is it's very often especially
you know I'm like the 1000 to the maybe
2300 level that you look at a get out of
position and you're like okay this are
my candidates move so let's analyze a
let's analyze B this a looks better
let's analyze a again let's go to scene
that's all I see again and you make
yourself a mess in the head and then you
play H and H what's your story